das ist wirklich ein ungewöhnlicher fund
auf dem mars und keine frage auf der
erde würde diese entdeckung ganz klar
auf leben hinweisen fündig wurde der
nas-server curiosity im geld krater
genau hier hat er das kohlenstoff
isotope c12 aufgespürt was steckt also
dahinter was spricht also für leben auf
dem mars und was dagegen klicks umsatz
im future gibt es dreimal pro woche
spannende science jesus abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasste nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen seit fast zehn
jahren ist klicks um science in future
ein wissenschafts kanal und eines der
großen themen der wissenschaft ist immer
wieder die suche nach außerirdischen
immer wieder wird die suche angetrieben
mit neuen programmen ideen oder
instrumenten wie jetzt zum beispiel dem
bahnbrechenden james webb
weltraumteleskop und die nasa bekräftigt
immer wieder bald werden wir sie finden
und tatsächlich gibt es immer mehr
spuren indizien aber wann ist es
wirklich soweit welche der vielen
meldungen der verdachtsfälle ist
irgendwann die meldung dieser fund ist
jedenfalls ein top kandidat auf einem
planeten auf dem zumindest früheres
außerirdisches leben vermutet wird das
könnte nämlich ein weiterer hinweis
dafür sein dass einst mal leben auf dem
mars existiert haben was konkret geht es
um die kohlenstoff isotope c12 und 10 13
forschungsteams der nasa konnten äußerst
ungewöhnliche isotopenwerte jetzt im
mars sedimenten aufspüren die der nase
rover curiosity im geld krater gesammelt
hatte und diese werte geben den
fachleuten rätsel auf auf der erde
würden sie auf jeden fall indizien für
einen biologischen einfluss also konkret
die einzige präsenz von leben gelten
doch wie können diese werte auf dem
roten planeten interpretiert werden
welche erklärungsmöglichkeiten gibt es
für den ungewöhnlichen fund auf dem
roten planeten und wie wahrscheinlich
ist es dass tatsächlich mal leben auf
dem mars existiert hat
methan oxidieren de mikroben gewesen
sein die ähnlich wie auf der erde
organische verbindung erzeugt haben die
antworten auf all diese spannenden
fragen und noch viel mehr gibt es jetzt
hier formiert je mehr auf dem mars
geforscht desto mehr hinweise gibt es
dafür dass auf dem roten planeten leben
existiert haben könnte und sogar immer
noch existiert doch der eindeutige
beweis dafür steht noch aus klar scheint
aber dass der mars früher einmal
deutlich lebens folglich er gewesen sein
könnte als jetzt möglicherweise
beherbergte er sogar ozean in der
fachsprache ist von einer sogenannten
habitablen phase die rede also der
lebensfreundlichen phase doch reichte
diese zeit aus damit organismen
entstehen konnten genau dieser frage
sind fachleute weltweit auf der spur und
ganz vorne mit dabei die nasa erst im
letzten jahr 2021 gab es eine
sensationsmeldung über die wir hier bei
kik substanzen future natürlich
berichtet hatten der nasa wo wir uns
hatte im seo krater des roten planeten
organische moleküle aufgespürt eine
super spannende entdeckung für unsere
suche nach außen neben fest steht
seitdem nicht nur um geld sondern auch
im zero krater sind organische
verbindung im alten hmas gestein
erhalten geblieben der mars rover
curiosity selbst der vorgänger von
personals hatte die organischen moleküle
im gale krater auf dem roten planeten
identifizieren können bereits vor vier
jahren 2018 hatte die nasa auf einer
pressekonferenz mitgeteilt dass der
rover
widerstandsfähige organische moleküle im
inneren von rund drei milliarden jahre
altem sedimentgestein aufgespürt hat
gleich an zwei verschiedenen orten
geldberater wurden diese organischen
moleküle in dem jahrmilliarden alten
gestein des mars entdeckt diese
enthalten laut der nasa fachleute unter
anderem kohlenstoff und wasserstoff und
möglicherweise auch sauer und stickstoff
sowie weitere elemente organischer
materie also sehr einfache
kohlenstoffverbindungen die hinweise auf
eine lebens- front viel zeit auf dem
roten planeten geben konkret handelt es
sich bei der entdeckung um aromatische
khalifa tische um telefonische
verbindung
hat es hier also möglicherweise nur so
von mikroben gewinnen die bisherigen
funde weisen darauf hin doch eindeutige
belege fehlen noch immer denn bei aller
euphorie es gibt eben nicht nur
biologische sondern auch nicht
biologische mechanismen bei denen
organische verbindungen entstehen
konkret können organische moleküle wie
kommentieren und die mitfahrt auch rein
geochemische stehen genau dasselbe gilt
für den weiteren möglichen hinweis auf
leben auf dem roten planeten
die fachleute ebenfalls für ein rätsel
stellt die rede ist von dem asiatischen
methan dieses zeigt sich äußerst
launenhaft einige raumsonden konnten
gehalte dieses gases in der
marsatmosphäre nachweisen die sowohl
lokal auch saisonal schwanken auch
methan gilt als potenzielles anzeichen
für mikrobielle leben doch auch methan
kann auf biochemische art und weise
entstehen beispielsweise durch die uv
bestrahlung von gesteinsmaterial um
herauszufinden welchen ursprung die
rätselhafte holen stoff verbindung vom
mars abend interessiert fachleute vor
allem der sogenannte isotopen gehalten
als isotopen werden atome bezeichnet die
dieselbe anzahl protonen und elektronen
besitzen dabei haben sie jedoch eine
unterschiedliche anzahl von neutronen
und somit ein unterschiedliches gewicht
es gibt stabile und in stabile isotope
der isotopen gehalt von marianischen
kohlenstoffverbindungen ist besonders
spannend für astrophysikerin und
astrophysiker da er sich je nach
synthese weg unterscheidet organismen
die auf der erde leben bevorzugen
beispielsweise das leichte kohlenstoff
isotope c12 und bauen es in ihrem gewebe
ein auf der erde gibt es also deutlich
mehr der leichteren c12 isotope als das
schwere c 13 curiosity war so
losgeschickt worden um an fünf
unterschiedlichen orten im geld vater
gesteinsproben zu nehmen 24 proben
wurden dann im so genannten same
instrument auf 850 grad celsius erhitzt
mit der hilfe des laser spektrometers
konnten die bodenproben dann auf ihren
isotopen gehalt hin untersucht werden
die auswertung dieser daten zeigt
erstaunliches die marianische proben
sind ziemlich verarmte die isotopen
gehalte in den proben waren zwar sehr
unterschiedlich doch 10 der proben
enthielten äußerst wenig c13 kohlenstoff
deutlich weniger als erwartet dazu heißt
es in der aktuellen studie diese proben
von sechs verschiedenen gruppen stellen
hatten 10 13 werte von weniger als minus
70 promille die proben enthielten also
weniger c13 isotope als erwartet worden
wären um das besser einzuordnen die
werte der mars atmosphäre für dieses
isotop liegen bei plus 46 promille auf
der erde und das ganz klar bedeuten hier
war leben denn es gibt weniger c13 als
c12 dazu sagt einer der beteiligten
forscher küsterhaus auf der erde würden
wir ein solches grundstoff signal als
biologischen ursprungs einstufen wo auf
dem mars müssen wir anders vorgehen wir
müssen erst noch verstehen ob die
gleichen erklärung auch auf dem roten
planeten gültig sind oder ob es andere
prozesse gibt denn der mars ist in
vieler hinsicht anders spricht
eigentlich spricht hier alles für leben
aber es müssen noch ausnahmen und
besonderheiten auf den mars gecheckt
werden anders als auf der erde ist der
kohlenstoff zyklus auf dem mars noch
längst nicht im detail bekannt dazu sagt
der wissenschaftler ende stil der an der
studie ebenfalls beteiligt war ein
großer teil des kohlenstoffkreislaufs
auf der erde beinhaltet leben und wegen
des lebens gibt es ein teil des
kundschaft kreislauf der asse den wir
nicht verstehen können weil überall wo
wir ihn schon leben müssen was wir aber
wissen der rote planet ist kleiner und
kühler als der erde hat außerdem eine
geringere schwerkraft und andere gase in
seiner atmosphäre der aktuelle von kann
laut der nasa vorstellen auf drei
verschiedene szenarien zurückzuführen
sein die spannendste erklärungs
möglichkeit allerdings ist mit
sicherheit die dritte erklärung
möglichkeit im ersten szenario hat der
kohlenstoff einen kosmischen ursprung
dazu schreibt das forschungsteam im
schnitt bewegt sich das sonnensystem
einmal alle 100 millionen dadurch eine
molekulare staubwolke analysen von
interstellarem sport aus dem agenten
methoden ergaben c13 werte von minus 2
16 promille hat der mars sich also in
diesem interstellaren staub und duscht
und der kosmische staub hat sich auf eis
und gletschern abgelagert im zweiten
denkbaren szenario stehen foto chemische
reaktionen von kohlendioxid oder methan
in der mars atmosphäre im mittelpunkt
der geschehnisse unter dem einfluss des
energiereichen uv-licht der sonne
könnten diese reaktion zur bio tischen
bildung und ablagerung organischer
moleküle geführt haben solche reaktionen
können tatsächlich zur selektiven
anreicherung schwererer kohlenstoff
isotope führen dass hatten laborversuche
auf der erde bereits gezeigt dagegen
spricht aber dass die gemessene
abweichung zu stark sind um allein durch
diese methan reaktion erklärt zu werden
die isotopenwerte passen tatsächlich
besser zur foto chemischen umwandlung
von kohlenmonoxid in organische
verbindungen wie format experimentelle
belege für dieses szenario aber gibt es
bislang nicht im dritten wird die
spannenden szenario wird vom
marianischen leben ausgegangen demnach
könnten methan oxidieren de mikroben
organische verbindungen erzeugt haben
ähnlich wie auf der erde fest steht
methangas kommt auch auf den mars vor
und das könnten maß mikroben dann in
ihre zellen eingebaut haben diese
biogenen organischen verbindungen
könnten dann als rückstand im nassen
element enthalten geblieben seid dazu
heißt es in der studie dieses szenario
könnte auch erklären warum viele proben
mit stark negativen c13 werden auch
reduzierten schwefel entdeckten denn
zumindest auf der erde hängt die
anaerobe methan oxidation durch marine
bakterien mit der chemischen reaktion
von sofa zusammen doch auch dieses
szenario kann die neuen erkenntnisse
nicht in gänze erklären die starke
verarmung an 10 13 wird durch diese
möglichkeit nur teilweise erklärt fragt
sich auch woher das notwendige methan
stammt in der studie schreibt das
forschungsteam noch einen weiteren
kontrapunkt auf der gegen dieses
szenario nummer 3 spricht es gibt keine
sedimente
zwischen belege die eine mikrobielle mit
an profi auf den einstigen maß um auf
welchen schützen wird heißt also nur
zeitliche bakterienmatten oder andere
lebensspuren wurden bislang auf dem mars
nicht aufgespürt das wäre dann neben den
niedrigen c13 werten den organischen
verbindungen dem methan in der
atmosphäre der letzte finale beweis für
leben auf dem mars aber wo können diese
eindeutigen spuren gefunden werden im
moment tappen die forschenden noch im
dunkeln dazu das fazit der
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
auf basis des aktuellen wissensstand
wird es schwer herauszufinden sein
welches dieser drei szenarien den
ereignissen entspricht die sich vor
milliarden jahren auf dem roten planeten
abgespielt haben wir brauchen einfach
noch mehr daten kommen sie zu bestätigen
oder zu widerlegen
wir werden also noch öfter über spuren
indizien hinweise auf außerirdisches
leben auf dem mars oder dem saturnmond
enceladus der venus und so weiter und so
fort berichten bis dann ja bis dann
irgendwann endlich mal der finale beweis
kommt die nasa meint schon bald ich bin
sehr gespannt doch leben auf der venus
ammoniak macht wolken der venus
bewohnbar anklicken ihr anschauen und
abonnieren das ist vollkommen kostenlos
und geht mit dem abo button unter jedem
video und hier klicken für das video bis
dann